so radical republican congresswoman  marjorie taylor-green of course had to  come up with the most absurd reaction to  the fbi raid of donald trump's house and  she certainly did first she posted a  picture of an upside-down american flag  suggesting distress  then she said that the political  persecution of trump actually started  under obama when they spied on his  campaign which didn't happen  then she started with the civil war  rhetoric which is what a lot of  republicans are doing and then she went  to defund the fbi not a very strong  supporter of law enforcement are you  marjorie if you want an entire  department defunded oh and also she's  doing the  they probably planted evidence at  mar-a-lago there is no evidence that any  evidence was planted at mar-a-lago